[Music]
we're going to do a uh a stunt now uh
and you're not going to do the stunt
you're sort of supervising the stunt and
we're going to do this outside yes okay
you guys want to come along for this
sure yeah yeah
andy's up for it and matt's like
whatever uh
and uh so we're just going to go outside
you want to lead the way and tell us
what we're going to do yeah well um i'll
be back folks
this is actually pretty cool because uh
it's one of those things we're sitting
waiting for the 3d cameras to be ready
and one of our guys was playing angry
birds and he was like man tommy he was a
heavy guy yes he said well if i was an
if i was on the thing you guys if you
were actually flying into me would never
be able to knock me off the perch like
i'd be too stout so we bet him a dollar
that he couldn't stay on the perch and
we used it as freedom flyers our version
of angry birds so this is your version
of angry birds uh and uh it is knocking
someone over using is this gonna be a
big wheel as well this is gonna be a big
wheel we also have a bungee cord that's
gonna propel dusty who's actually pretty
much the world's best big wheeler he's a
double back flipper on the big wheels he
does a lot of really cool stuff so he's
gonna aim for one of these guys okay
thank you all right here we go
and uh who's actually gonna do this
stunt right here may i talk to you for a
second hey how are you what's your name
uh dusty weigel okay dusty what you're
going to do is we're going to pull you
back this is a giant rubber band yeah
and you're going to be fired up this
ramp into this
simulation
more or less of angry birds except
uh instead of pigs it's human beings is
that right it's my boss okay and a
terrible idea all right no it's a great
idea uh it's my boss
okay well i would not allow this and i
employ a lot of people uh all right uh
we have been asked to tell children
watching at home this is not a good idea
you really shouldn't do this i said that
we're clear you're all set now are you
ready to go no do you have family my
mom's right there
hi she's so proud she's so proud yeah
she's proud she always knew as a child
someday you would ride a tricycle up a
ramp into some angry birds all right
let's do this we'll help you get back
how did you guys draw the short straw up
there
there you go pulling back we're all very
strong men
we're very very powerful we got it i'm
doing this with one hand damn you're
going to follow me at this point
[Applause]
ready to go
three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
this
go
this one
this one
incredible
it's a fantastic stunt
yeah all right
looks like everyone's okay
we're getting confirmation that
everyone's fine yes of course they're
fine all right that was a huge waste of
time travis thank you very much
and nitro circus